it was just after 8 a.m when the air
sirens went off moments later black
smoke over levi's skyline
four missiles struck one after the other
at a few seconds interval
one of them destroying this car repair
workshop in the northwest of the city
it took several hours for the fire to be
extinguished
the force of the blast dropped natalya
and her daughter katya out of bed
they fled their hometown of sevilla
donetsk in the east of the country a
week ago
here we were getting back to normal but
this attack took us back home when the
shells were landing around us and we saw
that neighbors on the ground it's
horrible to leave it once again
we feel hopeless
fatally doomed i'm an adult woman but
can't comprehend how to come to term
with that how to live further to find
strength to keep going this is scary
some employees at the workshop are among
the dead and wounded
three military installations were also
hit in the morning attack now a local
official says that the guided missiles
were initially aimed at ivano francis a
region south of lev and then at the last
minute were rerouted towards here
ukrainian officials believe the missiles
were fired from the east perhaps as far
as the caspian sea
at the same time similar scenes were
unfolding in other cities and towns
around the country kharkiv continues to
come under constant shelling russia now
striking deeper into the city center
and in maryupol ukrainian forces have
ignored an ultimatum issued by moscow to
surrender
holed up in a steel factory south of
this poor city despite being surrounded
and outnumbered by russian forces
ukraine's president volody merzelensky
has described the situation there as
inhumane
so far leve has been spared the
destruction witness in those other
cities it has played a vital role in
this war becoming the supply and
logistical hub for humanitarian and
military aid coming into the country
now the mayor warns no one is safe here
either
now in ukraine there are no safe or
unsafe places
everyone is under threat
i repeat my call to old residents
whenever you hear the sirens go to the
shelters because it might save your life
we mourn those who died but we have to
be vigilant
they are now smashing civilian
infrastructure
more and more will be coming
as russia seems to be shifting its focus
on the ground to eastern ukraine the
rest of the country remains very much
the target of its air power
hamid al jazeera live